has uh started and we're gonna follow
game three between anish giri and magnus
carlsen
magnus is in the lead he won game two
and anita with the white pieces we'll be
looking for a comeback yeah and uh look
at the bakaya because
white already according to the computer
has a big advantage that's not
necessarily saying that white's winning
he's definitely not but it's a dodgy
opening from magnus to say the least and
i'm not even sure the name of this
specific type of opening it might trans
uh
it might uh later go into what we call
the modern bononi
uh but yeah either way
yeah son of sorrow oh
sorrow that's how bad the opening is
no but uh the bononi it's at the top
level it's regarded as very dodgy for
black and computers don't like it but
uh yeah it is playable there are some
ideas and
uh magnus also used something very
similar against liam yesterday in his
defeat so
um yep this bononi opening magnus magnus
can't have great memories of it having
lost that game yesterday to the end but
maybe he's improved he's got different
setup in mind
and okay black does develop the bishop
to the long diagonal this is the idea
black's bishop now uh putting some
pressure on some squares and the reason
this is good for white according to
computers at least is because white has
a very strong pawn in the center of the
board white's pawn structure is superior
it's an interesting i've actually never
seen this position before with black
delaying the development of the night
usually you kind of make a very quick
choice you know you move it and okay
it's now
now we're back into mainstream territory
yeah the banoni is over and sounds like
baloney well no it is it is it is still
the bononi and uh the whole point is
that
white is going to be sitting on the
extra space and if you take a look at
black's light squared bishop there
that piece is
if you play it right it's going to be
the bane of black's existence it's not
going to get out it's not going to have
a future it's not going to do a single
thing and a white is going to sit there
with a big smile on their face
so this means that every pawn break that
black threatens to do your pawn
expansion white goes
no
i'm not going to go for that not going
to allow it so white if black picks up
the a pawn and push it one square white
goes no no no you want to push your b
pawn forward not going to happen
yeah and maybe we can show some of the
ideas uh there ivanka
there are a few ideas here for black as
you mentioned this is one of them
pushing a pawn forward trying to expand
with your pawns but white locks the door
and says no i'm going to push my pawn
forward i control this square i also
open up my rook potentially and nothing
to be done black can never really get
this pawn break in
you should also mention this problem
child this piece has no safe squares and
okay therefore
magnus brings his knight to the edge of
the board
it's a positional mistake here i think
to go and capture this knight because
now despite these double pawns black
does gain open lines in return and there
we go anish didn't capture he opens up
this would only open up the black rook
instead anish castles his king and in
this position after the rook move we do
see some pressure on white center a
niche though the other key idea for
white in these benoni setups is to
establish a knight on this square the c4
square is a key one at the moment it's
not possible because black's knight
would take a pawn but if the knight gets
to this square the reason it's the son
of sorrow uh at least as far as i
understand is because this pawn this
weak black pawn on the d6 square is just
eternally a target it's eternally weak
the knight targets it the bishop's soon
gonna come and target it uh it's a
backward pawn and uh it's just an
eternal weakness i hate these positions
for black because it's so hard to keep
this pawn intact you have to really
fight dynamically often giving up pieces
that's what magnus did yesterday
yesterday against liam he gave up a rook
for a night he gave up several pawns
just to get activity so this must be
just great news for a niche then
fighting for a comeback yeah i mean uh
this is what not to do in the opening if
you only need a draw for magnus but uh
we see that magnus likes to take these
kind of creative approaches and anish
still has a problem he needs to defend
this pawn before he gets this knight to
the dream square
all right so we did promise you um the
champions challenge with uh anish giri
after game two but because game two
between pregnant and liam lasted for
such a long time
we jumped straight into game three and
we're going to show you that champions
challenge with anish later on
and
game three with jordan from forest and
the young christopher judah has also
started the situation in that matchup is
that duda is in the lead he won game one
the second game was a draw
and uh jordan from forest with the white
pieces in game three
is definitely fighting for a comeback
eric hansen he won game one against
chakri and mohammed er but mom died he
did make a comeback in game two so they
are tied now playing game three and it
is mamadiara with the white pieces in
this game
magnus carlsen if he wins game three now
again stanish geary he will be the
winner of that match but so far i
understand it's looking good for anish
yeah
there are some ideas behind black's
position of course uh the bononi exists
as a as an opening for a reason but
yeah it's not a solid one for black and
there we go anish playing that idea we
mentioned pushing his a pawn forward
also look how white's pawn structure um
you'll love this one kaya with the pawn
stretchers white's structure on the
light squares that pawn chain is so hard
to break down often black might need to
even sacrifice a piece to break open the
position later and white's knight has
found its dream square and the black
bishop now going to try and exchange it
and i like what magnus has done over the
last couple of moves computers still
loving white but normally in the benoni
if you can trade off one set of minor
pieces whether it's bishop for night or
one set of knights usually uh that helps
black a lot and there we go the
evaluation by actually reacting i think
magnus should just trade off his
lightsaber bishop for the white knight
as soon as he can do it now and then
think later uh there we go and one set
of trades means that black's position is
far less cramped i mean a few weaknesses
now even i can see that all the white
pieces look super good yeah they do and
black has to hope that he can slowly
start to kick them back
i'm not sure i'm a massive fan of what
anish has done to be honest but uh okay
he still has full control i'm expecting
the white queen maybe to step up the
board now
and uh still magnus struggling for the
pawn breaks it seems seems like a pretty
typical but only position though to be
fair yeah i mean it might just be bad
but it's i mean if if you're going to
play this opening yeah as black could be
yeah you might you have to expect to get
this kind of position right so uh so
magnus can't be that surprised to to be
in this i mean uh uh again you know
mentioning mikhail tao just looking at
his games he played this
knight maneuver uh on the queen side
where black's put his knight in many
many times and many games and it can
really come to life if you can after
magazine's last move get the b pawn
going at the right moment if you can
just push that pawn at the right moment
the position can really explode explode
into action and with the black queen
maybe coming forwards to support that
the black rook going over one square to
support that uh i i don't know if it's
that bad at all for black really i mean
i i i would play this as black
yeah
i mean lots of players would love this
position as black anyone who's played
the bononi in their lives i'm pretty
sure they would take this and there are
worse benoni's out there but then again
still takes a while to support that pawn
push you mentioned that's the battle if
black can push the pawn to the b5 square
then he's doing well if not then he
might struggle anish meanwhile taking a
bit of a timeout again
to me it just feels like something's up
with anish his first game he took a draw
as white very quickly and he didn't
really need to second game he played for
a draw with bet with black
just very passive never got any chances
didn't work out and he lost
now he's playing very slowly again
losing a few moves here and there with
his king now i thought it was maybe time
you mentioned simon black wants to push
on the queen side on the left side maybe
white should try and push in the center
as quickly as possible yeah because just
hesitating yeah at least preparer you
know can you know move the queen current
connect the rooks
definitely try to make black struggle
with his space deficit but yeah
king moving to the corner very safety
first
um feels like he's a bit not scared but
i don't know he's just not trusting
himself right now not calculating at all
yeah i mean
it's kind of a it's a scared move kind
of makes some sense it's like okay i'm
gonna play this be super safe but i'm
not actually trying to do anything i
mean white's still doing absolutely fine
but it's it's these pawn pushers here
which are gonna be key black's one on
the queen side and white's got to try
and get this one in the middle i mean
another plan black has in these
positions is to move the h pawn and then
retreat the knight to kick the bishop
away i mean there's a lot of ideas here
as well so but this is still a fairly
typical middle game position though for
the bononi if you're going to play this
um
maybe i'm just being too harsh about
this king move it's the type of move i
would play as well but i'd hate myself
for doing it just
yeah because it's a it's maybe not the
most aggressive move out there
still a lot of play left in this one
sorry go ahead no okay i was just going
to say i was going to share some selfies
yeah so
whilst the players are waiting oh i'm
thinking rather not waiting um well we
have a few selfies richard harding says
it's a lovely evening in germany as
watching great chess with his buddy
tikki mickey
mickey chicky mickey yeah that's cool it
is a very cool
and uh we will soon bring up the selfie
we get
and uh there we see the pawn attacks the
bishop
the bishop will step back and if he's
ready for that of course he's going to
keep it on the diagonal pinning the
black knight still eyeing up the black
queen indirectly
and yep nothing much changing with that
last move
and uh well we are waiting for the
selfie sweater is uh ready actually with
that the coach the partner in crime for
anish giri irvin lemi is also here on
site in oslo
anish is currently playing his last
white game of the day and uh how how are
you prepared to get back into this match
well with magnus you never know what to
expect so it was actually magnus will
sprung the first surprise it was clear
that anish had to get a game going but
magnus seemed to have done that for him
playing a very sharp opening so um
i kind of like that because i think
that's what irish needs to get back in
the match
uh perhaps magnus is looking to maybe
even decide in
in this game already but
in general
i'm looking at the position behind us
there now and yeah it looks like a sharp
opening looks exactly like what we are
what we'll be aiming for
magnus also said that he's he's not
quite as able to think far ahead because
of his uh his sickness right now as he
would like to so he plays an intuition
is this something that a niche can
exploit
yeah it's very hard to say uh i still
think that uh despite him being a little
bit underwear he's still able to play
pretty decently as we've seen so uh
no i understand we'll just have to throw
everything at him to to to get back in
this match
and um
you have to say uh marcus is still
playing pretty well despite his i mean
the way he converted the end game in the
previous game was
was quite impressive i thought and also
how fast he did that without much
thinking but uh
yeah and he's still in it so i'm i'm i'm
so optimistic actually thank you for
taking the time over sure sure
urban let me he's feeling optimistic
knowing in each gear has to make a
comeback at some point
and uh
do you think it's going to do that in
that game i think it'll all depend as
owen said there on whether he can throw
everything at magnus so far he hasn't
had the opportunity really but
he would love to and i think he needs to
start attacking at some point in the
near future before magnus gets that key
break that simon was talking about black
pawns marching forward on that left
flank so
yeah critical moments will come soon
aneesh needs to speed up as well he's
been behind on time in both of the games
so far all right and super critical
moment right now in game three between
jordan van priest and young christophe
duda duda is in the lead in the match
and the bar is so far over to his side
and if he wins this game the match will
be over that's gonna be a loss for
jordan and zero points three points for
duda if he's able to win this game wow
and i'd love to keep an eye on jordan
just for a second because a massive
opening blunder from him what uh he just
walked into what is quite an elementary
trap and uh he's already under heavy
fire i think he's going to lose very
quickly in that game uh just a disaster
in the opening from van forest a
devastating start for jordan found for
east in the game uh he could be about to
lose the match game three with uh oh
look at him he's suffering that's not
nice to see but great news for young
christoph duda yeah duda looking good
ever since his first day defeat to
magnus he's
i mean yesterday he of course won that
tie break against nation
he's doing the double dutch beating the
two dutch players maybe in a row the
double dutch i like that
now game three with liam le and
pragnanda has now started it started 10
minutes late because they finished late
in game three and if prague wins this
game he will be the winner of that match
so far he's decided both
his matches and they also esports cup in
three games
he could do the same and this one with
liam with the white pieces
that's not easy what do you if you take
a peek at that position
is it
still very early days yeah still well
within opening theory that
so uh we'll keep you guys updated
absolutely craig's progress absolutely
and uh meanwhile a couple of moves the
white queen's stepping forward we
advocated for this a few moves ago and
now magnus has planted his knight on the
edge of the board he also went for
something similar against liam yesterday
but uh the knight does have intentions
to jump towards the white queen create
some nuisance there yeah here it's quite
thematic actually because the
the white bishop that's sitting on h4
feels a little bit misplaced
and the move that white would really
love to do is actually deprive the night
of jumping into that square but you know
that comes with a lot of risk and
black's queen gets very very active
yeah and
yeah white would love to kind of control
all the dark squares if possible but
that's the point of the bononi black has
a lot of dark square control
white's central pawns you can push them
forward but as ivanka said
that comes with downsides is anish gonna
throw everything at him now though is he
going to push some pawns i feel like
anish is probably a bit uncomfortable in
this position
um i mean in each type of position right
he prefers it much much more
safe and
controlled you know
making sure his opponents pieces can't
jump in he can't get attacked especially
when he's playing with white pieces so
this is kind of like i i really feel
he's going to be like
you know but especially as he's showing
signs of being nervous anyway uh to you
know this this could be it this game as
well magnus wins he wins the match so
it's a big game that is big big you know
you kind of forget that they are playing
a match situation and uh well the word
in my ear is that the tweets are ready
to read and let's go back to richard
harding's selfie who was having he was
enjoying a lovely evening in germany
watching our show and enjoying the chats
with his buddy chicky mickey uh there we
go cheeky mickey i like that name yes
not as good as course or as charlie the
chess cat nowhere near but it's still
good
it's still good
with it
and
also graham trevor
who is saying when your university
assignment is due but the oslo esports
chess cup is on
yes
priority interacting people don't we
yeah absolutely
and uh richard harding also has a ques
also clarifies an issue for us he said
that rook which we were discussing
earlier actually comes from the persian
term rook meaning chariot ah it wasn't
tower like i thought it was chariot
harriet well it would be so cool though
if the pieces were chariots you know
like zoom
like make special because then there
would be a song as well chariots of fire
actually that's sometimes my workout
music ah
sorry we need more singing today that's
it come on hang on no actually no no no
no no no no both don't sing this is
really unfair i've sung we need to hear
more singing okay so have it one two no
no
does anyone out there want to hear your
anchor scene no people actually people
have heard me sing on twitter ah there's
been a few videos out there okay
disappointing yeah everyone's gonna be
trawling through your twitter account
now looking for those videos david
himself has some videos of me singing as
well i've heard david sing you know you
have a pretty pretty good voice
very good yeah yeah
only after a few uh
oh what do you have in your cup
orange juice unfortunately
players yeah i do know a few of them who
do like karaoke as well a few other
players in this tournament i'll let the
viewers guess which players those are
seems to be a chess thing actually i've
heard several chess players really
enjoying karaoke and um
ask
that you all know he is the karaoke
expert he knows
there's no song he doesn't know yeah our
skill singing yeah
he's very good at rapping as well oh
yeah gangster's paradise we should get
oscar lynn here for a live show of the
gangster's paradise joined with david
david also knows the lyrics off my heart
yeah i'm not sure which player here is
walking through the valley of the shadow
of death
taking a look at his life realizing at
best now
i don't know anymore the lyrics but it's
like a big song yeah yeah meanwhile
magnus having his first real think of
the game look at the clock times as well
anish down to six minutes magnus just
under 11.
um
i'm starting to feel like this is a
dream position for black
the computer always always hates the
bononi but the fact that the computer's
in the middle means that this is one of
the best benoni's you'll ever see
and uh black's ready to break everywhere
i mean that's that's a good thing about
the board yeah you can break on the king
side the knight can jump in the pawns
can come in the center on the queen side
and you can combine it all at the right
time and suddenly everything comes
forwards um and uh yeah i'm not even
sure what well niche has moved his work
but
how how is that really helping yeah how
is it helping as you mentioned simon
black can play on both sides of the
board black and prepare this pawn push
you can't really play it right now maybe
you could consider it but this square is
covered sufficiently by white it's
covered once twice three times and uh
black's only defending that square twice
after the pawn recapture pawn takes pawn
knight takes and white winds upon
temporarily at least uh but you can
combine threats of this one maybe with
threats of pushing the f-pawn forward
very thematic you could maybe push this
pawn forward to control even more dark
squares another move i would be looking
at is something like dropping the bishop
into the middle of the board because now
you do create a threat maybe of hitting
this white bishop which lacks escape
squares
but yeah simon as you mentioned black
doesn't even need to rush black can just
prepare these pawn breaks you can even
make an argument for bringing the rook
across pushing this pawn forward you
would love to play this move i guess to
prepare uh the pawn push b5 but the only
question is whether white can get greedy
and grab opponent okay magnus goes for
something similar but uh he plants his
bishop in the center instead
interesting controlling some dark
squares controlling this diagonal
and anish very quickly i was going to
say he needs to drop his bishop back
because he needs to slowly take control
of the dark squares by pushing this pawn
forward and pushing the other pawn next
now i mean i guess it still is in the
balance david i i would say but i mean
it it seems like black's just more
comfortable at the moment over the last
uh series of moves that's more flexible
than white i guess yeah but i i have to
say
my experience is even though sometimes
black guests everything that they want
from the bononi they still have to tread
with caution they still have to play
very actively because
take a look at black's pawn on a d6 the
one in front of the queen that's so weak
and if you don't handle the position
carefully that is going to be the target
for the rest of the game yeah all the
pieces disappear this is still a target
um it's hard to get out right now for
white but uh yeah i just remembered the
words of english grandmaster nigel short
when i once played a benoni type of
structure with the white pieces and i
had basically similar to this but an
accelerated version an even better
version and he said even the worst
bononi is still a benoni
so
it's uh no even the best benoni is still
up in a sorry yeah uh so yeah magnus
despite having everything he could want
from a bononi still the computer hates
his position so um it looks like he's
preparing this move but it's not clear
whether it's a threat right now
for example if white just makes a move
then pushing the pawn forward would
result in a lot of traits rook takes
rook and white would still win a pawn
temporarily at the end i'm not sure this
guy is so important but uh okay magnus
threatening at least hinting at this
pawn push
and gary needs to spend time thinking
about it yeah it kind of reminds me of
that story actually
um i remember in the olympiad 2018 i did
everything wrong with the white pieces
against the bononi and i showed my game
but somehow i i've played some
resourceful moves and i showed my game
to david and i remember david's words
yeah whether they say that even the best
bononi is still really bad
and uh somehow
white is still alive you know white
always has chances because the pawn
structure is so dynamic yeah unless you
give black literally everything he wants
unless you let black play on both sides
of the board then
normally you can control things
sufficiently yeah
okay look at this clock time though i'm
really worried for giri fans because
under five minutes now and still the
real action hasn't happened yet
it's still very much tip-toeing around
each other
kind of a mind battle right now
and to have four and a half minutes
against carlson's nearly nine minutes
it shows he's not confident he's yeah i
think he's just struggling to find a
plan isn't he i mean like uh he you know
you want to still do something um
because you can see magnus is improving
bit by bit and again another another
move here which
is probably like a sense bullish move
but it's not really doing anything this
move i mean he's trying to bring it over
to a decent square but again what's he
doing with this move and
magnus's move controlling dark squares
trying to push a pawn they're all doing
something yeah i have to say i often use
this particular rook maneuver if black
has uh played and a very committal move
on the right side of the board you know
pushed his g pawn two squares forward
and i like this type of move because the
rook
funnily enough is actually getting ready
at the right moment to swing across and
join the fun on the right side but here
i have to say i'm not that impressed
because black's pawn structure on the
right side is stable i mean i guess the
golden question is here is can black uh
push the pawn he's been
gearing up to push
and you know if he can push that then
he's going to be doing very well because
it will win a piece even so but can he
go b5 i mean that is that's critical
here right yeah that's critical but
magnus rather than think about whether
he can push he first got his i got his
spotify in order and he got his get
psyched mix on and maybe he's getting
ready to
maybe he's listening to chariots of fire
pushing that pawn forward uh what
workout music do you listen to david i
don't work out and i don't listen to
music that's not true
i've seen i've seen pictures you down
the gym once a year maybe
no no no david's very fit actually very
yeah yeah under all the
i tried to hide it but uh don't try to
hide it okay maybe we can we can jump in
simon you mentioned this one move yeah
for the viewers and there we saw the
screen magnus yet to click on any piece
and he's thinking about this one and
simon what would happen here i guess a
porn trade i guess i guess white wins
porn uh okay he hasn't played it
started with this but it's still
relevant uh the night jumping in yeah i
mean my idea was okay white's going to
win a pawn but you go rook b8 at the end
a very sensible move trying to get the
rook down
uh that that be
so for example trading off all the
pieces and at the end here bringing the
record something like rook b8 i thought
because you i don't see how b2 is going
to be um defended and then black's
pieces the one thing with bononi is that
uh if you can get your pieces into the
position suddenly you get great tactical
play and it's normally black's pieces
which uh make the banoni such a fun
opening to play i mean it is one of the
most fun openings to play it's a pity
that is probably dubious but you always
get chances to attack with your pieces
so um
that's that's the point of him yeah even
at the cost of a pawn if you can open up
lines for your pieces you could also
make an argument for maybe trading a set
here and then uh trying to find a safe
square for the queen the rook is
definitely going to come down to the
second rank at some point and start
hitting things okay wow gary didn't put
his queen on the diagonal i was going to
say he had to because keeping the queen
on this diagonal makes it more difficult
for black to break out and i know stats
he just blundered a piece or not he's
just no he i don't think he's blunted a
piece but he's allowed okay like they've
been the perfect structure on the left
side
i i avoid doing this type of stuff you
know i never let black do that wow okay
incredible but even a good bononi is a
bad banone still a banoni yeah
it always feels a lot more dangerous
when you've allowed that potential pawn
structure because somehow the long-term
advantage has now suddenly gone all the
way over to black yeah long-term black's
doing great now i mean these two are
going to beat this one in any end game
yeah look how strong black's bishop is
yeah yeah looks great for black the only
thing you have to uh watch out for for
magnus carson is white starting to
expand on this side pushing the knight
back next move once it retreats pushing
the bishop back so white is getting
ready to push forward pawns but
it looks like carson is i mean he's the
moment a standard idea if black would be
to push the knight away and bring his
knight in to the center um but you do
give away squares that's the problem
yeah i mean this is you get squares but
you also give away squares maybe to the
white knight
so really complicated strategic battle
right now but uh magnus ahead on the
clock and
with the momentum on his side i wouldn't
be surprised even if he pushes a pawn
forward on this side
just to make it more difficult for white
to expand for example to drop back
suddenly it's hard for white too he has
response and okay he's done it he's done
it
and remember everyone the late night
show podcast with the niche geary
comes out
tomorrow it's published on wherever you
watch or
listen sorry to your podcast but if you
are hs24 premium member you can
exclusively see a video version of it on
chess 24 if you go into chess24.com and
click on collection you'll find both the
late night show podcast video edition
and
the chess talks with ivanka the one with
liam lia has been published today so
check that out after today's games it's
half an hour
a very deep and nice talk with liam lee
and we have some moves we have some
moves and just as expected it's a fight
now for this f4 move so anish giri if he
gets another opportunity if he gets one
more turn he's going to pick up the
white f pawn push it forward one square
kicking black's bishop away from the
center and if he can do that then the
kickback begins maybe he has some
chances it's not clear whose king is
going to be weaker
if the position opens up magnus
meanwhile very sneaky move his intention
if white pushes a pawn forward now to
kick the black bishop is maybe for the
black bishop to even capture the white
knight and suddenly white's pawns in the
center of the board would all start
falling like domino's
so magnus trying to spot gary's plans
and prevent them there is a pawn up for
grabs though and it's your idea simon
if the white knight goes and grabs
black's b pawn then we would see a trade
of pieces and black's rook as we showed
in that previous variation we'll just
slide uh slide across to the b file and
start infiltrating into white's camp
really tense still in the balance but
the clock times might decide this one
hard for white to keep control
and the queen is sort of heading around
as well to go behind the bishop
and improve that diagonal hits hit some
other things so so
it looks yeah it looks like a good idea
white's position is full of weaknesses
actually yeah yeah so many holes and uh
i'm just thinking back to that king move
all the way back you know it's totally
unnecessary i mean white could really
have done with
making an extra move here but of course
like you say now black is active the
position is full of holes there's no
plan of advance magnus's last move so
good
if you see an opponent's plan try and
stop it if you can and
what is the niche going to do and the
clock is reflecting that just under two
and a half minutes
it's getting really dire for a niche
i mean i think one of the things that
beginners make a biggest mistake doing
is they only look at their own plans and
i've always said like chess is about as
as we see in that last move you have to
do your own plans but you have to stop
your opponent's plans and you know lots
of people they just don't stop their own
you know their opponents plans or only
think in one way traffic and this is the
first thing to improve
look what your opponent's doing and try
to stop their plans and then you push
your own plans at the same time uh okay
well anish now trying to get in those
light squares david with the bishop um
okay but i don't really see what that
does to be honest so i mean the bishop
looks nice and pretty but it's just
hitting thin air right and bishops even
if it gets to a nice outpost bishops on
outposts aren't as strong as knights on
outposts and black is the one with
knights with a relatively blocked center
in the middle for now the black knights
could start creeping in at some point so
i like those ideas that you both
mentioned the black queen kind of
sneaking in to the asic square attacking
some loose pawns maybe black's pawns can
start advancing already that's where
black has the majority and you should
push on the side you're stronger
kick away the white knight with one of
your pawns maybe and i was just going to
say that bishop moving to the diagonal
actually has some consequences because
once you've kicked away the white knight
suddenly the knight sitting on the c7
square whoa can actually jump
back into the game and it's actually a
much better time to do that because
white's maneuver previously was to bring
the white knight around where the the
bishop is so uh i i think that's just a
very simple way to play yeah look at
anish he's expecting magnus to push upon
and hit his knight because he's
highlighted his own knight he's ready to
retreat it yeah so that's the move he's
expecting that's the move anish is
assuming magnus is going to play the
pawn to attack them why is he not
pre-moving it because uh he can't
pre-move it just in case black doesn't
do that black goes for something else
then moving the knight might not be such
a good idea for example if black's queen
okay it does happen actually and he
moves it very quickly but if black's
queen had attacked a loose pawn then you
need to take a timeout to prevent it you
couldn't have moved your knight it
doesn't look happy as well i mean you
can sort of see it's always interesting
when you're playing chess the body
language and you can even do that here
in the esports arena that i know myself
i've been told that when i've got a good
position i'm like i sort of lift up but
when i got a bad position i saw just
like you know
and i just sort of fold away into the
chair and
i think you can see his his face is down
his hand is there and he's sort of you
know he is slumbered a bit and he's
highlighting he highlighted the queen
and now he highlighted the bishop
so he's uh thinking about the potential
and talking about this another trait
that you have simon but maybe it's more
when you were younger i want to hear
this yeah it was when simon was
calculating he always did
oh
that's because i got excited you know i
had too much agenda and i was like
that must be really off-putting well i
was like what's that dog the churchill
dog
you know those car dogs in the window
the back of the car yeah you just do
that was i i couldn't be that bad
it's very sweet yeah i have one when i'm
in time travel i kind of arch my back
and i do i kind of sit there like this
get ready to pounce yeah but one thing
about anish is when he doesn't like his
position he does cover his face quite a
lot yeah he's normally just kind of more
stoic if he's enjoying the position okay
he changed his mind three or four times
there we were watching the screen he
clicked on his bishop he clicked on his
pawn he clicked on his queen earlier but
then he went back to it eventually and
yeah he's stopping the black knight
jumping into this left side of the board
white's queen on a nice diagonal but he
really doesn't like his position does he
just this indecision the kind of
structure and we have to remember if
magnus wins this one he wins
he does it so it's over and uh one match
is actually over young christoph duda
winning game three against jordan from
force has decided that match is over
it's three points four duda zero points
for jordan in that match-up mom and
daughter of and hansen have also
finished game three with a draw so they
are still tied after three games
and liam and pregnant on that they
started ten minutes late and the bar is
it roughly to the middle in that one
remember if pragnando wins this game
three he will be the winner of the match
it's almost a must-win situation for
liam he needs a draw and he has to win
game four if it is a draw yeah and
meanwhile a really cool move from magnus
carlsen there sacrificing a night
temporarily and just before we switched
away we saw nishigiri shake his head
because he missed this move and suddenly
it's all about black that night was
black's worst piece and now it's jumped
in and uh we have to show why this
knight can't be taken it looks like uh a
beginner blunder but there's a sneaky
idea behind magnus's uh move there if
the queen takes this black knight which
was just up for grabs for free then not
taking this pawn queen takes pawn would
be a mistake because white could block
and attack the queen but first before
that move taking the white knight off
the board removing a defender and
actually putting white's rook on a loose
square it's all about loose pieces and
after queen takes pawn check you hit the
rook you hit the bishop you hit
everything and you win next move you
just take the rook and black's position
is winning so uh anishigiri instead of
taking this knight
after it jumped forward he had to take a
timeout to defend this pawn first but
still maybe no threat of capturing this
knight because if it gets captured then
the black rook will still take white
tonight
i'm expecting magnus at some point to
start jumping in with this piece you can
make an argument for this square this
square
both look good this is disgusting for
the niche i mean you know
he's everything's just going the wrong
way he's trying to he's trying to crowd
his king with all his pieces when he had
this big space advantage you mentioned
earlier this nice way of going forwards
it's gone the opposite way for him and
uh
this is the thing with the opening i
mean you know we're saying you know
white is better the computer hates
black's opening but when black comes to
life it's like a jack-in-the-box when it
comes to life is really really dangerous
with those pieces
they're just so well positioned every
single one and i expect magnus just to
move the knight in somewhere now and
jump that knight in and just play and he
has done i think he's moved the knight
into the middle of the board fantastic
night and um you don't want to trade it
off because then black is completely
dominant on all the dark squares look at
this bishop controlling everything
caging in this white knight the knight
stable right simon this nice stable that
famous book um
fishing chess and fishing yes you forgot
just in case anyone forgot going uh you
might not be able to google it because
it's so rare
it's incredibly rare but um yeah i mean
that incredible domination of the night
and meanwhile let's go back to the
players because magnus was making some
facial expressions there widening his
eyes maybe not so sure about things
maybe he had a plan and he realized it
wasn't so effective i mean he could
maybe go after this pawn at some point
he could maybe try to start pushing
harry the h pawn when in doubt uh that's
often a good idea what is magnus gonna
go for
looks very good for black but maybe too
much choice and now magnus for the first
time in the game under three minutes he
needs to speed up the bar is loving it
though for the world champion do you
think he's winning this game or what do
you think david yeah um it's i mean it's
just the trend is all in his favor uh
the last 10 15 moves magnus is improving
every move anish looked a bit
not clueless but unsure of a plan
uh so it's definitely in black's favor
but you still need to be quite careful
and you still need to find a plan and
okay he does push simon uh you must be
happy to see this move because uh yeah
it's very logical isn't it i mean i mean
magnus is now controlling uh the board
and he's just trying to make more
weaknesses with this move more more yeah
both both everywhere at the center as
well dominating everywhere and there's
no there's no way that white can uh
initiate any form of chaos by pushing
any pawns because
it's just not possible just giving away
material and you mentioned the toy jack
in the box hated that one it's creepy
creepy very creepy yeah yeah there were
some creepy little toys weren't there as
a kid i mean jack in the box jumping out
i think that was the point it was creepy
actually yeah
and music boxes i never got them as well
you know yeah they're really creepy
meanwhile a really desperate move uh
not quite a creepy move but a desperate
one by uh anish geary and after this
trade of bishop tonight white's pawns
are just weak and dropping off can you
get a creepy move do you think there's
such a thing as that could be crawling
you can creep you can creep forward but
can you get a creepy like scary you know
creepy move scary for your opponent
maybe yeah and it's very scary for
anishgiri right now 30 seconds and in a
hopeless position look at the white
pawns white has doubled pawns on the
f-file one of them's about to drop
white's pawns on the left half of the
board as well isolated and weak
oh he's weakening his position even more
now just to keep his pawns alive but
takes pawn though and uh after pointing
uh change her attention her focus over
towards the white king
yes sorry sorry go vanco the rook can
also step backwards onto the second row
the queen you can come across like you
mentioned um
yeah really instructive actually and uh
also a lesson actually and a warning to
the white players on the side of uh
bononi you know don't be complacent
don't waste
time don't just trust the computer you
have to look for plans instead
i mean this is something that people do
far too much nowadays they look at a
computer assessment and they say i can't
play the bononi because the computer
says it's bad but but only's been around
longer than you know it's been around
for you know i don't know how many years
but hundreds of years probably so you've
got to make your own judgments and look
at this white has been forced to retreat
because there was a checkmate threat on
the board the black queen and the black
bishop combining to attack the pawn in
front of white's king so the bishop now
a sad piece retreating and this is
complete domination look at white's
pieces apart from the queen they are all
on the back rank
they're all pinned down tied down
defending things and
magnus can just win at leisure here he
can just move the black king he can just
move the black queen
there we go attacking a pawn white's
queen stretched to the limit now
anish about to slide her across to
defend some pawns but the white queen is
having to defend two or three pawns
it's not an ideal situation and uh okay
changing his mind again a niche under 30
seconds
magnus is on the brink of winning this
match
yeah and he's looked i mean let's look
back to his best magnus today 19 seconds
for anish he has to make a move if he
wants to
stay in the match but it's such an
uphill task to defend this and so he
just uh now is desperation but perhaps a
little bit too
late pushing pawn forward queen jumps in
but you know
there's no danger he's only attacking
with his queen every other piece is on
the back rank and if you just compare
the pieces here i mean all the black's
pieces have got a great role in the
position they can even improve so
it should i mean it should be game over
now yeah i think really nice game though
i think uh and you know against liam lee
yesterday that was incredibly exciting
the bononi as well um
i mean yeah maybe magnus should do a
chattable course on the bononi it's
making it interesting uh it's a really
fighting opening it is a fighting
opening uh not for those who
don't like risk
and uh
no never
no i mean i love playing against it so
much
right i don't think i could ever enjoy
suffering with it i might give the
padoni a while against you next time go
for it i invite you oh challenge at
september okay i think ivanka will play
slightly differently to how anish has
played this game though yeah
i've only played it myself a handful of
times i think in my career as black
maybe five six times okay meanwhile okay
black did retreat the night i'm not sure
about that one it feels like a bit of a
slow move by magnus he's getting greedy
he wants to maneuver his knight
okay i mean
the other thing is is when your opponent
is in time trouble sometimes it's best
to play a move that is just a nothing
movement because your opponent is
normally in a position to react against
something but when he doesn't have to
react he has to think
and uh he moves his king allowing a rook
check now
maybe there's some other options as well
hell yeah white's rook uh sorry the
black or it could uh check on the second
rank and white would be forced to block
that uh i guess we do have the saying as
well look at the black knight the knight
on f8 there is no mate so magnus just
wanted to play a bit of a defensive role
with that night but i think it's time to
go after some of the white pawns there
is um
a little tactical point to exposition
and uh there is
no i was going to say bishop takes pawn
but that would not be possible because
uh there's an attack on the h2 spawn so
no not even that when's bishop purely a
defensive piece i mean i think here
black can switch to the other side of
the board um and this is a very typical
idea to get a past pawn he could have
gone c4 i'm okay swapping queens that's
quite i
that's yeah sadistic's the right word
but he's given a pawn check
yeah so why why has he done that i mean
that that seems very peculiar to me so
white could have taken the pawn next to
the queen with a check
i mean and he's also getting short time
magnus as well and why didn't he go c4
that's what i was thinking c4 must have
just won out right i mean and then you
queen the b pawn simple he wants to win
an endgame magnus but it's not so easy
at least the white knight is activated
maybe we've written off giri too soon
but gary five seconds there oh he did
make a move and the queens have departed
i mean you don't always have to win in
the ending right you can't you can win
before the ending when your name is mr
carlson you like to win in the ending i
think mate he knows you're commentating
he wants to get to 100.
he's on the board side there okay now
he's played it so this this is this is
convincing because yeah the pawn will
just simply run through to its
destination it's unstoppable now if this
black pawn is captured then it just gets
replaced by another pawn black's b pawn
is the one that wants to promote and
okay a check from gary he's trying to
fight but it's just too slow if the
white knight jumps back now and captures
the black bishop black will ignore it
he'll just push his pawn forward and
that pawn is destined to become a queen
magnus is going to get a new queen
for the second time in this match and
he's going to win again for the second
time in this match that's it isn't it i
think game over yeah and match over yeah
evaluation bar says plus seven for black
now that's because black is about to get
a new queen white can pick up a few
pawns pieces on the way maybe but the
queen will decide the game
and okay the knight is jumping back to
try and stop this from happening but the
knight won't be able to stop the black
from promot black pawn from promoting
black's bishop as well can block off the
night's retreat what's gone so horribly
wrong for a niche today
he just didn't look confident he was
slow he wasn't playing aggressively
against magnus especially when magnus
isn't 100 healthy you have to be
aggressive um because he had that you
could beat him because he had that
perfect opportunity in game one didn't
he but he got the perfect opening to be
aggressive and uh instead he swapped
everything off and offered a draw and i
think that was as you mentioned at the
time david he was he said he was very
happy
but that was a terrible mistake i mean
that was the golden opportunity in game
one to go for a win and go for checkmate
literally just go for the kill
um so very strange turning point already
in game one but that's when the momentum
switched purely to magnus that's when
magnus realized gary was afraid of him
so a few checks there from white the
black king though finding a safe square
and
a queen coming on the board next move
nothing else to be done gary is about to
throw in the towel and resign
it's over
magnus carlsen wins the match against
geary in three games gaining all three
points